[Music]  honoring our heroes a group of  motorcyclists rode through las vegas  today to honor the men and women of law  enforcement who died while serving  six riders are traveling more than 22  thousand miles across the country  as part of the end of watch ride to  remember all to honor fallen officers  organizers say this event serves as a  reminder for families who have lost  partners and friends  that they are not alone this is just a  stark reminder for everybody of  the men and women who wake up every day  put a uniform on go to work  and in 2020 we lost over 330 officers  nationwide so that's you know a very  telling number and  this tribute is just really good for not  only our community but this will travel  across the country and  remind the families that this country  and the people in this  great nation of ours have not forgotten  their loved ones who gave their lives in  the line of duty  the end of watch ride honored 146 fallen  officers  across the country last year